foreign
talk to Sarah what's up Sarah
hey Dr John it's so great to talk to you
it's super great to talk to you man how
we doing
I'm good I'm hiding in my closet from my
kids that's right
um that's what moms do in the summer
Kelly just raised both hands and said
preach sister what's up oh see I know
I'm
not you're totally alone I'm just
kidding what's up what's up no so my
question was I guess I phrased it how do
I better handle my anxiety and my stress
in the summertime
and so to give you a little back you
know background I am a wife and a mom of
three active boys
uh eight almost 10 and 12.
it's Rowdy over here I bet so
[Music]
yourself are you a teacher
oh yes I meant to add that to the end
yes I am a teacher what years
um well I'm Elementary but I'm I jumped
into special ed this past year okay
so can I just say thank you for your
service
you've been deployed and you're back so
thank you God Almighty that's a tough
road
so when did when was school out
um we got out about a week ago
um actually it was both right
Memorial Day
um so I'm kind of a week into like okay
finding our group as a family no no
there's no Groove yet
okay okay so I'm trying to give myself
Grace mom gets two weeks to recover
y like at least two weeks
that'd be awesome my boys are like a
thousand miles an hour I know I'll I'll
walk you through how to deal with them
but mom is all of this starts
so my guess is that anxiety is a couple
of things number one your body's fried
it's cooked you're exhausted I've been a
teacher you're done you get done and you
collapse and then some idiot in your
life's like oh my gosh it's so great to
get Summers off and it's like bro I'm in
recovery like I'm not this isn't off
I've been working 6 a.m to 8 P.M for the
last anyway
so number one your body is trying to get
your attention and be like we can go no
more we can go no more number two
probably you tell me if I'm wrong your
husband doesn't fully grasp the severity
of everything
and he's um
just business as usual
he is no he's amazing he's wonderful he
carries helps around the house like
carries the load with me
um but he is okay so a new piece of this
puzzle is he just started working from
home about a year and a half ago oh fart
in a box on a stick yikes that's a lot
of dudes in your house
yeah it's a frat house
there's pee everywhere oh geez
so I think like in March literally March
or April I'll have a day where i'm like
I need to talk to you and he's like is
it is it are you getting nervous again
about summer I'm like yes like the
groceries I've been to the grocery store
every day like the kids eat constantly I
try to force the schedule and they they
just it just feels like chaos sometimes
and I feel like as a teacher
I'm used to and they are as well being
kids in school is like routine structure
like this is every minute of our day is
calculated and then when we have
summertime unstructured play is so
important but it's also like the Devil's
Playground like they go nuts when
there's this freedom and we we do plan
things and we have friends we go hang
out with or we'll go somewhere but we're
not spending tons of money and we're
trying to live within our means really
well
um and I have I'm jumping in
because if you were here I would ask you
permission if it was cool just give you
a hug for a second no you do me a huge
favor
yeah I want you to take as deeper breath
as humanly possible I don't want you to
hold it for an awkwardly long count of
five okay
like as deep as you can ready one two
suck in as much air as you can
hold it one
two
three four
five and when you exhale I want you to
pull your shoulders down as low as they
will go
okay now you just sit there for a second
okay number one
you are not a bad mom for wanting space
between your boys and your husband
got it
yeah the next time you tell yourself
that I want you to
say hey Sarah I talked to this YouTube
guy he said that's not true
okay
you're not a bad mom for wanting to
break
you're not a bad teacher because you
have three knuckleheaded boys and you're
quote unquote supposed to be the expert
on all this stuff and you don't know
what day it is
what happens is you get in this Loop
that well I must be terrible at my job
but it must be terrible at home and I
must be terrible at my wife and what
kind of mom does he want to be around
her kids I finally get time off and you
get in this death spiral and you end up
in your closet on the phone with a
podcaster
right
yeah yeah okay unstructured play is
incredibly important for kids
and
so are ridiculously firm boundaries
so creating time and space Here's what
that looks like
it looks like you calling a family
meeting with the boys
and saying prefacing it with this is a
grown-up conversation
and they will go and they'll look at
each other's side-eyed and kind of get
all tough and and you tell them stand up
tall stand up straight it's a grown-up
conversation
and don't get all Wiggly waggly
and then you tell them beginning
tomorrow
mom
is off limits until 10 A.M
um
mom's off limits
what you're going to give them is an
Incredible Gift of watching their mom
rest
and recharge and recoup
and they're going to take this lesson
into their marriages
they're going to take this lesson with
their girlfriends they're going to take
this lesson into the workplace
when they have exhausted pregnant moms
working for them who are also incredible
at their jobs
so you're I'm talking about total
life-changing Legacy change by simply
telling your boys mom's off limits until
this time
and you you've heard of your teachers
you've heard of conscious discipline
just the framework so one of the
cornerstones of that framework one of
the one of the Seven Pillars or whatever
you call it is choices
I found out once that my wife was
actually doing this to me and I didn't
even know it she's a teaching Guru but
here is your options for breakfast they
get two choices and they get to own the
choice
here is the options for between the time
of 7 30 and 10.
you will go outside but also you won't
leave the yard so here's two or three
things you can do in that time
if one of you violates this all three of
you fill in the blank here's the choice
you'll have made and here's the
consequencer accountability
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to slowly give these boys some
autonomy within some really strong
fenced walls
and they're going to feel like they're
pulling one over on Mom they're going to
practice autonomy they're also going to
be safe they're also going to break
stuff but it's going to be in a place
that you design things to be broken in
and Mom is going to wake up slow and
have coffee and read and journal and
stare off into space and put her feet up
outside on the front porch
see what I'm saying
yeah I was thinking about like
um you must do these things like in the
morning time you get to pick
when you say must they go to war
when you say here's your two choices
they feel like they win
right it's this it's what it's what my
wife did she's like
um we can go to
um Mexican food or pizza and I'm like
I'm the man of this house we're having
Mexican food that's what I'm talking
about and she got what she wanted you
see what he's saying so we're not the
moment you start going to must and you
have to
the moment those boys and you
desperately want them to Buck that
system because one day their government
is going to tell them you must and
they're going to go do we like and
that's that's kind of that's the kind of
men you want to raise
and so we're gonna give them practice on
how to give Mom space
give them practice on how to honor mom
and dad and they're gonna test they're
gonna run their little 8 and 10 and 12
year old heads up against these
boundaries and see if they hold
and with a smile on your face you'll say
Hey you chose to interrupt me between
when I woke up in 10 a.m so you just
chose for absolutely no screen time
today at all none zero I hope tomorrow
you don't make that choice
yeah and they will get that message real
real quick when Mom's firm
yeah I feel like I've been really rigid
before where I'm like okay we're doing
this this and this and this and this
like with a schedule of our day but you
see how you see you're you're telling
them what they're gonna be doing instead
of inviting them making the choice
that's right okay and it's it is Magic
inviting them along for the ride in the
lessons Downstream are beneficial now
I'm gonna tell you this right now
there's going to be some morons on the
YouTube channel who come those boys need
to be told what whoever says that is
stupid they're dumb they're just dumb
it's dumb it's not good for them short
term it's not God for good for the
middle term it's not good for them long
term
because you're you are in the process of
raising men you're not in the process of
curating a summer vacation for an eight
and a 10 and 12 year old
also you and your husband
who's I in no way am I saying he's a bad
guy not even close he's probably an
amazing guy I trust you that he is
I didn't know what I didn't know
and it wasn't until the school year was
over that my wife started saying okay
here's what I've just been through
here's what I need the next 30 days to
look like
that I got a picture of her world
and so it's really easy for me as
husband a guy who loves my wife who's
involved and engaged with my kids
to just wake up June 1 and it's business
as usual
and I've got a wife suffering from PTSD
who's who is also now full-time
stay-at-home mom and not fully recovered
yet so it's important for you and your
husband to go okay
what is June going to look like what's
July going to look like what are we
aiming towards
what is camps who's going to drive who's
going to pick up how does this impact
your work from home all of those things
let's just go sit down and say okay
let's dream together what the things can
actually look like
what's our picture for the summer
because the picture might be your
husband's had a pretty quiet house to
work from home
and now he's got three Maniacs in there
and a wife who is listens to a lot of
murder podcasts and at some point
they're not going to find your kid's
body because you know what to do you see
what I'm saying like he's gonna expect
but his picture is business as usual
your picture is God I need some help and
so all both of those are great you just
gotta sit down and and navigate that
together
yeah yeah
can I give you one more thing
yeah that time until 10 A.M
if you use that time until and I and by
the way I just picked that number
arbitrarily it could be nine o'clock it
could be noon I don't care what it is
that's for you and your family but there
has to be some protected time for Mom
that your boys get to see Mom is
honoring her mental health and her
physical health and our family by taking
putting her oxygen mask on first they've
got to see that and it's Gotta Be sacred
time
yeah you can go ahead
I'm one of those
um
weirdos that goes to work out really
early fantastic
so they see me come home you know they
know where I was but then they're like
Mom I want this mom want that and my day
just goes like I just yeah and you wake
up and it's 2 45 p.m and you just start
yelling inside I just I
crazy
crazy I don't like that it's okay but
but I want you to take ownership of the
craze it's not these rambunctious little
boy's fault that they're rambunctious
little boys thank God they are
it's the structure and the balance and
not balance I hate that word it's the
structure and the boundaries inside that
house
so I'm going to tell you something
that's really hard but I'm telling you
because I love you
the crazy that you're feeling is crazy
crazy you are allowing to happen
and so what I'm telling you is to just
take ownership of the day and you gotta
have your husband's buy-in on this
so I'm glad that here you say I get up
at 5am
it's real easy to fall into the Trap of
just do nothing in that Holy sacred time
and I want you to be intentional about
that time whether it's exercise whether
it's calling your mom whether it's
writing letters whether it's going to
have going to work out at 5am and then
meeting a friend for breakfast at 6 30.
that'd be awesome
yeah it would be
put that on your calendar and let your
kids know yeah mom has her special
breakfast with on Tuesdays and Thursdays
yeah I have a hard time relaxing my
husband will type that out
I'm like he's on the couch like after
we've cleaned up or done something you
know after dinner or whatever and he
just sits and I'm like how do you just
sit he's like it's good for you you
should try it okay can I ask you a real
hard question this can be kind of a left
turn
oh sure
let me try to ask this in a polite way
where did the I'll ask it how I asked a
caller on a previous show where did that
ticker tape that runs below
you know when you watch the news that
little thing has a stock market
underneath it just running and running
yeah yes underneath the the movie that
is the life of my friend Sarah from
H-Town my hometown
your ticker tape just runs and says
you suck at all of this you're not good
at any of this you're not good at any of
this
where does that come from
I don't I don't know if I really say it
to myself I know but your body
experiences it and here's how I know
okay because you
are unable to prop your feet up and let
your knuckleheaded boys run around
because you think I'm quote unquote
supposed to be fill in the blank
the supposed to be and the shoulds Never
Stop in your heart and mind
yeah sheds not a great word no and it
dominates your life
yeah I don't know I feel like
um I
I just I don't know I growing up I had I
have amazing parents and my dad was
always traveling he's a pilot and so my
mom was just
she she was doing everything while dad
was gone you know and I think I just
maybe it's just like my vision of what
being a mom is it's like you're non-stop
you're serving your family you're like
not you know and yeah go go go go okay
you just did like a Year's worth of
therapy in 30 seconds
here's your magic here's your magic
moment are you ready
sure yeah I want you to take your
husband out for a half day just half day
pay for the babysitter or whatever you
got to do
don't leave those three boys because
they'll they'll burn your house down and
you know that yeah yeah I want you to
take your husband out
and I want you to explore this one
question
husband who I love who's amazing what is
your picture of a wife and mom
not what do I think it is because both
of you can talk and you're going to use
the same words but you're gonna have
very different pictures
and I want you to paint a picture of
what you think the perfect mom is the
perfect wife is the perfect housekeeper
is whatever words you want to throw in
there
now I'm almost guarantee you that your
husband is going to be like I that lady
scares me
and I think you nailed it I think your
body's running an old script that it
picked up from an awesome mom that you
had
you got to do this you gotta do this you
got to do this you got to do this but
the message underneath that you got to's
is you're nothing if you don't
and I think that message would stun you
if you were honest about it and it would
stun your husband because he loves you
he knows you're incredible
I know you're incredible
so let's build a life
I say this all the time let's build an
unanxious life in our home starting with
Mom puts her oxygen mask on first
mom takes care of mom so that she can
lean in and be a maniac with these boys
and of course we're gonna go to the pool
of course we're gonna go to Camp of
course we're gonna go to the zoo
whatever other junkie got going on we're
going to the Astros game or whatever
but every day starts with Mom honoring
mom and mom having Sabbath and rest and
peace and whoo and Mom and Dad building
a life together that's sustainable
throughout the summer so that we can go
back in to be a teacher in the fall
I'm so proud of you I'm so grateful for
you stay on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of own your past change your
future it's got some ex some steps on
how to build this life I'm talking about
and I can't wait man I wish it was in
the fall because I got my new book
coming out I can't wait I need to get it
get you a copy of it when it's out
um but it's not out yet
um just to lay out the steps here but
you are on the way Sarah thank you for
being brave